okay i want to talk about something that
is unfortunately going to become a trend
which is people finding ways
to get a
pseudo
res real i guess i would call
uh exemption
for either
vaccination or mask wearing okay as we
see more and more requirements put in
place even if the requirements are what
we would call like a soft requirement
where it's like
you got to get vaccinated or you can
test weekly so you could just test
weekly as we are seeing more and more
schools including in the state of
florida say no no no to ron desantis
even if you don't want masks in schools
we the school board are putting masks on
these kids because they're unvaccinated
and we need to do it it just makes sense
you're going to see more and more
shady mechanisms for people to try to
get themselves or their kids out of
wearing a mask or getting a vaccine
there is a chiropractor offering mask
medical exemption notes in
florida
business insider has a report a florida
chiropractor issued over 500 mask
exemptions for students in sarasota
county
um
a chiropractor in florida okay as i said
district spokesman craig miniglia told
the herald tribune a third of all
medical exemptions in the district
were signed by chiropractor dan bush at
twin palms chiropractic one guy one guy
the county started imposing mass
mandates on students on monday defying
florida governor ron desantis executive
order banning mass mandate that's last
monday this all happened over the last
week
after rumors started circulating that
bush was giving out pre-signed medical
exception forms sarasota county school
superintendent brennan asplin issued an
updated mask exemption form on tuesday
mask exemptions can now only be issued
by licensed medical doctors osteopathic
physicians or advanced registered nurse
practitioners bush had denied
accusations that he was giving out
pre-signed forms i myself will tell you
i have not given exemptions to any
parents i have not met with
that's different he also says i'm not an
anti-mass person or an anti-vaxxed
person but i'm pro-freedom pro-choice
sarasota is one of 10 school districts
in florida going ahead with mandates
mass mandates against the governor's
order two school districts have had
funding withheld but are still
continuing with the mandate of course
florida's seeing a spike in covet among
children
cases among children under 12 up 30
percent the week ending august 26th
cases among those 12 to 19 up 26
so check this out
um
this is video
from uh an event in
florida
where people are
lining up in order to get exceptions
from this guy people just all lined up
working hard to prevent their kids
from having to wear a mask this was an
event held by this guy
um these are pictures of armed guards
at the event let me see if i can put
them now
you know
typically
uh
you wouldn't need armed guards
with um
what i guess are bulletproof vests or i
don't know if you call it a flak jacket
it's it's looking even a little small um
and and long guns
in camo i mean like typically you don't
need that when you're doing something
medical in this way
um people saying how could this possibly
be legal
and one of the things that keeps coming
up is this
promo this event took place yesterday
mask exemption
evaluation event so that's important
right you got it you got to call it an
evaluation event
sunday september 12 at noon
826 south moon road in venice this was
yesterday and it says parent guardian
and student required to attend
so they have to be there
medical records helpful
but not mandatory so you can just show
up and be like you know
my kid struggles to breathe with the
mask or whatever
and then um i guess the good the good
chiropractor
would say
ma'am or sir
your kid qualifies for this thing now i
wonder if customers have to sign sorry
sorry patience customers the i wonder if
the patients of this chiropractor have
to sign a disclaimer
so that if the maskless relative or
someone that gets the virus from them
dies
they can't then go and sue this
chiropractor is that something that they
have to sign and imagine what is going
on in your head
where
never mind saying i think i'm gonna find
a mask opt out for my kid
i think i'm gonna go and stand in line
for maybe hours to get a mask opt out
for my kid like what is going on in
people's lives what is going on in
people's heads that that is something
that they would go and that they would
do this sort of reminds me you know in
in the early days of medical marijuana
and as a reminder i believe it should be
recreationally legal and regulated and
all this stuff
in the early days of medical marijuana
there were
sort of what you would call like pro pot
doctors
where
you could just go
and there have been some investigations
on this about how sort of silly it was
you go in and you say
i need a medical marijuana card because
my back hurts
and this would be a doctor you had never
seen before and they would have you do a
couple movements and they would say and
tell me where it hurts and then they
would just kind of like generically say
yeah here's a prescription for your
marijuana and you you get a card and
then you go and it was like sort of
understood
you know you're paying a couple hundred
bucks for the console and it's basically
just like a rubber stamp type thing
this seems like the same thing the
difference being
someone just going and getting medical
marijuana when maybe they should really
only be getting recreational hurts no
one
and it actually potentially keep someone
out of the
out of dealings with law enforcement for
something that shouldn't be a law
enforcement issue altogether all these
parents going and opting out their kids
from masks
actually has a societal effect and can
actually lead to we see more kids than
than at any point in the pandemic in the
icu and in the hospital for covid but
also then they bring it home to other
people it's a mess and it has a huge
societal effect but the the the consult
strikes me as some of what was going on
early
um with the absurdity of of the medical
only marijuana which is a very different
things uh uh it's it's different
medically
and it's different societally as well
this is not boding particularly well for
us exiting the pandemic anytime soon